I believe there's never ever been a time
in human history where we are more
confused than we are today let me say
this one more time
I believe there's never ever been a time
in human history where people you and I
are as confused as we are today let me
explain to you why you see if you were
to go back a thousand years ago and you
and I are living in a family where our
father's a farmer what do you think
we're gonna do when we grow up we're
probably gonna be farmers what if your
dad's a cobbler you're probably gonna be
a cobbler carpenter carpenter it doesn't
matter you're probably gonna do what
your father does and you're probably
gonna marry somebody within the
community because it's a small village
it's a small city and the traditions
that we have the church we go - we don't
have millions of different options right
that's a thousand years ago go back 200
years ago maybe we have more options but
come to today if you want it to today
you have more choices and options today
than ever before
on career on religion on politics on
social media on content to consume on
dating if you wanted to have 10 dates
every single day starting at 6 a.m. in
the morning at the gym till 10 p.m. at
night at Starbucks on Saturday and
Sunday you could set it up today you
just got a swipe right you have so many
options today why commit to anything why
get married why commit to one career why
believe in one philosophy what so this
whole thing has made it so challenging
being an eighteen year old today is got
to be the most challenging time ever to
be 18 years old if you don't have the
one currency which I'll talk about here
in a minute let me go a little bit
deeper on this topic so the other day
I'm holding a conference call and on the
conference call one of the guys asked me
a question st. Pat how do you figure out
a way to stay sane today and still have
a family life I'm married I got three
kids eight year old six year old three
year old I run two companies I got
employees investors and lawyers creating
contests up combined together trying to
exercise stay in shape kind of find out
what's going on with the economy with
the news how do you keep all that
together and not lose it how does that
happen and for me I went to one place
one simple place you see every single
year at the end of the year I take a
piece of paper and I write down what was
Pat like at 18 and I go 18 19 20 21 all
the way down to my
age today and I finish it would one
thought here's what the one thought is
is the 41 year old path today hungrier
strategic wiser Chi then he was at 35
meaning if the 41 year old path was to
compete against the 35 year old path who
would win if the 41 year old pal were to
go to against a 40 year old Pat who
would win what is the difference between
the 32 year old Pat versus the 41 year
old Pat what has changed
now some time when you say this a lot of
people said well Pat I'm wiser than I've
ever been before
okay all of us are if you think about it
the more mistakes you make you're gonna
be wiser the more you travel you're
gonna be wiser the more books you read
the more new people you meet somehow
some way more life experiences just
means we become wiser right but hungrier
different story what do you mean by
hungrier though am I supposed to be as
hungry as I am you know at 28 as at 40
am I not supposed to be a little bit
more calmer calmer yes hungry different
story let me explain why we have two
people running for office today okay
both of them are in their mid 70s
Sanders and Trump and they are hungrier
than anybody else today why is that it
is Trump hungrier today than he was at
40 think about the 74 75 year old
President Trump going against 40
year-old Donald Trump think about if the
75 year old Sanders is going against the
40 year old Sanders who's hungrier why
say in any competitive environment if
you and I were to go into any
competitive environment but business
sports it doesn't matter what it is the
moment you decide to compete every
morning you wake up you fall into one of
three categories you're either a hunter
trying to go find your prey you're
either someone's prey who's trying to
hunt you or you're collaborating with
somebody else to go hunt for something
bigger just like what just happened
today with t-mobile and Sprint they came
together to try to go against AT&T or
Verizon once it gets approved they're
collaborating but if you don't hunt
anymore
you will be hunted that's just the
environment where it that's why
sometimes business gets a black eye
because it's constant competition so
what's the solution to this here's what
the solution is
if you're talking to yourself writing
you asking yourself you're 50 years old
are you guys hungry you ride 40 I don't
know you got answer that question but if
you're not as hungry as 40 you may be
someone's pray today somebody may be
coming after you today and how do you
get that hunger again very simple go
back to when you were hungry and think
about the state you were in you'd watch
a movie like gladiator and you start
getting emotional because you'd say oh
my gosh I want to win so bad I want that
feeling of redemption like this guy has
you watch movies with Redemption it gave
you juice it gave you power it gave you
strength and give you encouragement in
ways nothing else was giving you at that
time ones the last time you felt that
way huh when's the last time you put
yourself in a position to feel that way
when's the last time why not just
because you're aging doesn't you
shouldn't be hungrier you ought to get
hungrier because you have more tools and
mechanism and strategy and ways of doing
things better today I'll finish with
this thought you know I told you earlier
the most valuable currency today it's
also the hardest currency but if you can
get this currency on your side it's
going to be very hard to compete with
you today here's what the one currency
is the one currency today that will give
you an edge in a marketplace over
everybody else if you know how to
concentrate on one thing you have an
edge if you know how to concentrate your
efforts and be focused on one thing you
have an edge if you can be focused on
one thing and I look at everything else
that everybody else is looking at 50
different philosophies 75 different ways
to make money 19 different streams of
income if you can figure out we go here
all of that stuff's gonna come your way
but if you go chase all the other stuff
like everyone else's you're gonna miss
the whole point of winning your life
because you can't concentrate
concentration today is the number one
currency you show me anyone today who
knows how to concentrate I'll show you
someone that nobody wants to compete
with because it's very intimidating to
concentrate and today's them so yes it
is very confusing today we are all over
the place today I totally understand
where you could be here today but
imagine if you could concentrate what
would life look like
imagine if you went back and started
being hungry like you once were before
combined hunger and concentration you
know what you'd be capable of doing
anything you want to do if you stay
hungry and if you can stay concentrated
at a time where the world is confused
today
[Music]